hey guys welcome to DLM MODEL LIFESTYLE
I'm photographer Nikita-Joien with
Model  You-tuber and my husband Daniel
Maritz
hey guys what's up! and today we are
doing a request video from you guys for
model photoshoot tips for photographers
yeah
how many tips are you gonna give them?
today I'm gonna give you my 7 best ones
all right cool shall we start? yeah let's
go
and hey just so you know I'll add the
links of all the equipment that I'm
using in this video in the description
down below so be sure to check it out
okay so let's start with tip number one
number one is when planning your photo
shoot. guys when you do your research
please send some reference images to
your models. why you might ask
remember the model needs to know what
the look and the feel and type of
outfits are, the location that you're
going to shoot in. they need to know what
is expected of them so they can go and
prepare some poses or expressions or
something like that
and if they do test shoots then they can
prepare their own outfits as well to fit in, right?
yes and then remember to do
location scouting. I cannot explain to
you more how important this is guys.
because if you pitch up at a location and
you are not prepared. it looks very
unprofessional and very unorganized yeah
you just save a lot of time and then
ensure that you are set up before the
model arrives. that's very important
because if the model arrives and if
they still need to wait half an hour or
an hour maybe for you to just first set up the
lights and things like that
you are wasting very precious
time for your clients, as well for the
model. yeah it's the worst thing if
you're a model and arrive at the studio or
location and you have to wait for an
hour or sometimes I've waited for two
hours and it's just like: you're stealing
people's time and it's so unprofessional.
yeah so that brings us to tip number two
and secondly guys when the model arrives
make them feel comfortable. yes that's
very very important you tell him why yes
because remember not all the models that
you'll be shooting with will be
experienced models. for example some
might be very new. it might even be
their first job that they are going to
so they will be very nervous and anxious
and even though they know maybe what is
expected of them remember the first time
when you for example did a photoshoot
you were nervous too
so it make them feel comfy. play some
background music maybe discuss the
reference images again discussing the
stuff and how the routine and the schedule
of the day will look like. puts them a
little bit more at ease, right Daniel?
yeah be very friendly when they step
into your studio or when you just see
them for the first time ask them: hey do
you want a coffee or tea? yes I just love
photographers that ask me that question.
yeah and even sometimes when I do a
location photo shoot for example: I will take
the model and the assistant or even if
we are a group or something I will get
them to go and have coffee quick and we
will discuss some things over coffee, and ask them some questions:
are you studying at the moment? are you
working? what work are you doing? remember
don't be too invasive and ask too many
personal questions but asking a little
bit about them will also make them feel
important and yeah... if you have a better
relationship with the model then the
photos will look a lot better as well
because then they feel more comfortable
with you. Yes and that brings us to tip number three
all right guys so now you
start your photo shoots and what you
usually do is now you test your camera
settings and your light settings ans stuff, right?
right please don't just pick up your
camera and start shooting away
communicate with the model yeah just
think of the model first okay. Don;t let them
stand there and start posing for half an
hour and giving you all these nice
facial expressions and stuff. Tell them: sorry sir
madam Daniel, I am going to test the light settings
first and I'm going to test my camera
settings so just stand and relax I will
tell you when we start, right Daniel? Yeah  most
of the professional models they will
know what you're doing right but the new
models they won't have any idea when I
started you know I went for it you know. I just did my posing thing
posing and then after 30 minutes or 40
minutes they say okay Daniel I think
we've got the settings let's start the
photo shoot and I will be like, what? I thought we already done...
okay guys and then another important
important notes but this is
probably the most important thing that I
can tell you. it is to keep communicating
with your model remember after the first
few shots you'll immediately know if the
model is getting the feeling
and giving you the correct poses and stuff
that you want and please don't get up
and tell them: you are not giving me what
I want, this is not the right way that
you are posing and things like that
if they're not giving you what you want
go to them  show them the
pictures first of all that so they know
what they look like right? and then
tell them something like that arm
looks very nice and this pose is very
nice but maybe try and do a little bit
of this and pose like this and direct them
show them some ways
don't be mean. yeah you have to build
them up, don't break them down with
negative stuff all the time. so when you
go to them say: hey I love your eyes
in this one I love your your hand or
pose or just give them something right
yeah and then you go on to explain hey
maybe you can change this a little bit
like this or so then when they do the
right pose or right expression then you
just tell them great job now you're
doing great. this is what I want awesome and
then you'll see their confidence just
grow. yes remember you are the mirror
they don't have a mirror in front of
them to know what they look like.
there is a thing like over communicating or
over complimenting someone don't be too
invasive. or you know... it's very clear for
experienced models like for me to see if
photographers has this habit of great
good right good
good great awesome great great it just a habit
you know, so there's no real
meaning behind it. I don't like to work
with photographers like that.
I like the work with photographers like Nikita
when she's seeing a really good shot
good pose she's saying like "right I love that
keep it keep it keep it" all right
lets move on okay. next is tip 5
and photographers
you also have legs, remember it's not
only the model that needs to move around
or that can move around, except for if
that is the job requirement or if the
client's want you to take the picture from the
front for example like e-commerce
e-commerce yes... you can move around
a little bit. Shoot from this angle move a
little bit to the left shoot from that
angle. yes you do that mainly
at the end of a photo shoot when you
have the specific shots that you wanted, but then
you can play around at the end a little
bit more. but when shooting on location
and the client gives you a little bit of
freedom to shoot different angles and
stuff do that. move around, move around
the model and shoot from different
different directions and different
angles. so tip number six number six
okay so second last tip
guys during your photoshoot. if
you're doing different outfits remember
you can also change up the music a
little bit to suit that specific look if
you're doing for example a sixty
style shoot'. play some sixties music
Or if you're doing a very vintage style
business look you can even put up some
jazz music some nice Blues music just to
get the model into that right feel. yeah the
right music just really helps them to
get into the the whole feeling of the
clothes and everything. yeah. It is the worst
thing if you don't have any music at all
and it's just quiet ...
remember when you're doing
photo shoots guys depending on the job
requirements for the clients, please take
breaks in between. when you get to three
hours that you've been shooting non-stop
you do get tired and you do tend to lose
some focus okay so take a break have
something to drink
have something to eat, just re-energize a
little bit and then the next two to three
hours will be fine
yeah experienced models will probably
ask you hey let's take a break here but
new models they would try and
impression you and they are not sure if they can
or not. sometimes they'll just be quiet
and then you just see the energy is
dropping so just ask hey are you okay do
you want to take a break and then
they will probably say yes let's take a break
then take a break.
yes so that brings us to tip number seven
okay so for new
photographers, remember they are a lot of
editing programs out there but the best
one is still adobe Photoshop
why? because Adobe
Photoshop is used by most of your
professional photographers and it also
gives you the best quality images after editing
yeah so if you're starting out
it doesn't matter what type of
photographer you are or want to be
you need a good editing software program so
start early with Photoshop so you really
get the hang of it and we'll also add
the link in the description down below
so be sure to check that out and then a
bonus tip
have some fun guys I know that
a lot of people say that if you laugh
and stuff it's not very professional
but remember you need to have a
balance have fun
laugh, be in a good mood, because that will
automatically flow over to your model
and the people around you. when you are
having a good time, they will also have a good
time and then you'll get the best
pictures. yeah that's true the worst
thing is to work with somebody that's just arrogant
and they just suck the energy
out of the whole photo shoot and it's
just aaaagh...it's worst job. so if you're positive
if you have that nice kind of
life-giving energy and you come to
photoshoot and you're like: hey guys, then it
just changes the whole feeling. even the
models they just feel like ah I can do
this thing and they give their best for
you as well so that the pictures it
comes out great
yes alright guys if you liked the video
give it a thumbs up subscribe and make
sure to click the bell so that you don't
miss any of the next videos and that's
it right all right you guys, bye!!
subscribe and remember to click the bell so you many..ughh  so you many, hahaha, ok let's try again
guys....(I forgot what to say)... no man...hahaha...
we are doing a model shoot tip....forgot  what to say....